aliés canadiens et mexicains.
Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
- Et c'est le président
américain qui fait crisser les
pneus de cette voiture
électrique pour prouver qu'elles
sont aussi eitititititititititi.
- En tournée au Michigan pour
vendre son plan surBiBiBiBiBiBin
martèle le même message : "Buy
American, achetez américain."
- "Nous créons des incitatifs,
pour les Américains qui achètent
des véhicules électriques
assemblés aux États-Unis.
On veut s'assurer que
au Michigan", dit-il.
Mais tout ceci crée un terrible
précédent.
Joe Biden est issu d'une famille
de
proche des syndicats est plutôt
sceptique par rapport au libre-
Ilsususususuadé que Donald Trump
a volé le vote des travailleurs
du parti démocrate, dit-il,
-  a a a a américain", répète
Joe Biden, trois mois après
son élection, devant un CongrèÇé
sa devise tout au long de saagae
qu'il respecte à la lettre
et qui n'est finalement pasfifi,
de Donald Trump.
u u u u u u u u u u u u u u u l
qui stipule que l'avenir estuxÉs
Américains.
Il veut renforcer sonenenenenene
protectionniste, au grand dam És
devraient au contraire renforcer
leur partenariat avec le Canada.
Si on veut concurrencer avec
l'Asie, il faut repenser le
développement de l'économie
La rupture des chaînes
d'approvisionnement à cause de
la pandémie a une fois de plus
Le Canada a comme levier les
matières premières, dit-elle,
mais aussi le secteur
manufacturier.
À moins d'un an des élections de
mi mandat, la priorité de
Biden et de regagner